اسمعني انا ابدا معك اولا بتقييمك لصفقات
الاستحواذ على الشركات الناشئه في بدايه
هذا العام احنا اشرنا لصفقه مهمه تمت في
تونس وراينا صفقات مهمه ايضا في اوروبا
والولايات المتحده كيف ممكن نقيم اقتناء
الشركات او عمليه الاستحواذ على الشركات
الصغيره شكرا لك وموضوع حيوي ومهم للجميع
لنا كمستثمرين وللشعب العربي بشكل عام
بالنسبه لنا سماع مثل هذه الاخبار يعتبر
بادره امل ومحفز كبير جدا
للشباب الذي يبحث عن اثبات ذاته واثبات
نفسه في ميادين كانت حصرا على مجتمعات
معينه
والشباب العربي اثبت قدرته الكبيره جدا
المعرفيه والمهنيه والحرفيه من ناحيه
المهارات التي اكتسبها لتطوير بلدانهم زي
ما ذكرت في التقرير ومثال
اللي ذكرته في التقرير مثال مشرف لنا
جميعا كعرب ويثبت انه نهضه بلداننا لن تتم
الا بسواعد ابنائنا بس لو قيمنا المشهد
العام بشكل عام للشركات الناشئه في
المنطقه العربيه الى اي مدى يمكن ان نرى
فيها امل مثلا لحل المشاكل التي تواجهها
بعض الدول يعني في في معاناه مع صندوق
النقد الدولي هل يمكن ان تكون هذه باب
مثلا
للمزيد من الدخل في هذه البلدان بالفعل
يعني احد يعني الاهداف المعلنه والغير
معلنه لدعم الشركات التقنيه الناشئه في في
مختلف البلدان هو لتنميه اقتصادياتها وما
شهدناه يعني من دخول مستثمرين عالميين
لشركات تقنيه محليه سواء في السعوديه او
في الامارات او في مصر او في في تونس او
غيرها من البلدان العربيه
اكبر دليل على يعني
الرؤيه الواضحه لدعم مثل هذه الشركات منذ
نشاتها وهو بالفعل يدعم اقتصاديات المنطقه
ويجلب استثمارات
للمنطقه ويدعم كذلك المهارات المطلوبه
لتنميه وانشاء مثل الشركات التقنيه التي
تخدم مجتمعاتنا والمجتمع بشكل عام